welcome to the Google cloud platform
education series my name is Jeff Davis
and in this session we'll discuss
building applications that scale
automatically with Google App Engine
we'll be running a moderated Q&A during
the session so feel free to ask
questions using the ask your question
here field on the screen in front of you
let's get started
so the format of this session will be
we'll start with a demo and this is an
in-depth demo of a relatively
sophisticated application that will show
the magic of App Engine in automatically
scaling to meet demand as well as how
easy it is to manage your application
once it's in production coming out of
the demonstration we will have a
high-level discussion about the range of
Google App Engine features and how best
to leverage them we'll take a few
minutes to talk about where you can get
more information online after this
session we'll talk about best practices
for evaluating Google App Engine for
specific use cases in your organization
and again we'll be right doing a running
Q&A feel free to ask questions as we go
so let's cut over to a demo this is a
customer success application running on
top of Google App Engine we work for a
company called better dev Joe and better
dev makes among other things a video
conferencing application so here we have
a mock-up of a video conferencing
application and users can perform calls
so this is a one-way call you can
actually see me in the studio right now
when they hang up it's going to record
information about this call into a
back-end database and what we're really
interested in as a vendor is we want to
make sure that we know all this ways
that our users interact with our product
and then for each customer we want to
know where there are opportunities to
improve their outcomes and optimize our
chances at renewals and upsells so here
we have a customer success application
this is being used by better dev they've
actually bought it as a SAS product from
another company called success HQ but
you can see this dashboard gives the
customer success
managers at better dev insight into
their various customers they have a list
of projects here that are underway that
they maybe should be paying attention to
they have upcoming renewals and they
have trending changes in usage and
engagement with the product so you can
see for instance that the calls per week
for skills feed one of our customers has
gone up by 30% if you click on any of
these you can actually get a dashboard
that gives you a whole bunch of detail
about how users within this customer are
actually leveraging the product so for
instance the team Davis account they've
purchased 10 video conferencing devices
to go with the software they have an
annual contract value of roughly $25,000
a year and we can see the trends and
their engagement with the product so
when i refresh the page this is actually
loaded live from the back end data
that's been recorded as users interact
with the product so we have purchased
devices registered devices registered
users percentage of devices provisioned
calls per week stuff like that okay now
what a customer success manager would do
with this is they would look for
opportunities to improve the customers
engagement with the product so for
instance first thing that we notice is
only 60% of the purchased devices have
actually been registered we should get
those other ones plugged in and going we
also notice that the calls per week is
trending down over time so this shows
the last 30 days and we actually want to
boost this up not have it go down on the
other hand we can see that support
ticket volume has gone down and end of
call ratings are slightly going up so
those are positive things that we could
bring up in a quarterly business review
with the customer now this is super
helpful when running a customer success
organization and we want this
application to serve our needs as we
grow as our customer success
organization organization gets bigger
and bigger we want to be able to serve
more and more users and as we have
and more end users of our
videoconferencing product we want all of
that data to be able to be ingested into
the backend and thus rendered in widgets
on these dashboard without any
operations overhead on our part so let's
take a look all of these charts are
being pulled out of a back-end data
repository we're using Google bigquery
which is Google's petabyte scale low
cost data warehousing solution you can
see that we actually have a table of all
the events so we have the date the type
of event whether it's a call or a page
load or a comment or a dial in session
who did it what company they work for
and then some other information if you
look down here at the bottom you can see
that we have five hundred and twenty
five thousand events have been recorded
now I was just doing one call at a time
and so that's writing one event at a
time into this back-end data warehouse
but what happens if there are hundreds
or thousands or tens of thousands of
users we want to make sure that our
application doesn't fall over but I'm
not a real expert when it comes to doing
operations so I would like Google to
take care of all of that for me and just
to show that this is actually all on the
up-and-up let me go back and I'm going
to bring up the better dev dashboard and
you can see that this is showing that
we've done 2,600 calls roughly in the
last week if I go back to this UI and I
do a new call hi and then I hang up if i
refresh this view it should actually so
2633 so you can see that it updated my
use of the product flowed event data
into the backend and then that back-end
is being rendered in a nice
visualization here so let's take a look
at the architecture what we have here is
customers these are users of the video
conferencing software and every time
that they use the product it's going to
write an event to an event API
servus so this is an API and it runs
separately from the front-end of the
customer success software that shows the
visualizations and all it does is record
data into bigquery now again if we have
lots and lots of users we may need lots
and lots of servers to catch all the
incoming events and write those events
into bigquery then the folks who are
using the success HQ product these are
the CSM s they actually hit a web
application which renders the front-end
as well as all the data visualizations
and this front-end can read data from a
memcache service which is a stored in
memory data store that is shared across
all of the front end servers it reads
and writes information about users and
companies into cloud datastore which is
a no sequel database and it reads all of
the necessary information to render the
dashboard widgets from bigquery this
architecture shows you one thing right
away which is the app engine is a great
platform for stitching together multiple
back-end services from within Google so
you want to use a gate data store and
you want to use bigquery and you want to
use memcache no problem App Engine is a
great place to stitch those together
another thing that we'll see is I've
actually broken my product into two
different services these aren't quite
micro services there's sort of macro
services but this gives you the idea
that you can actually split your
application into discrete components and
then we can manage those components
separately
let's take take a look at what's
required to actually put this all
together in production so behind the
scenes here we have App Engine and you
can see that in the App Engine console
I've got my two different services
running so I've got the API events
service and the default service which is
my web front-end and you can see that
I've got instances that are
automatically running so for the
front-end App Engine is currently
running two services and if you look at
the API event so you can see that it's
currently running one service what would
be great
is if when nobody's using either of
these services it would spin down to
zero instances and therefore it doesn't
charge me anything at all but then I
wanted to scale up to dozens of servers
or instances if the load requires that
and in fact let's let's try that out
let's just see how this auto scaling
stuff works so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna use my SAS growth generator if
only it was actually just this simple to
generate growth in its SAS business so
I'm gonna start with generating a low
background load of new events so this is
emulating a bunch of people using the
video conferencing product and it's
writing events into the back end what I
should see here if I look at the events
service is I'm gonna stay you'll notice
I've got 27 requests there's a little
bit of delay and updating this but
you're going to start seeing that those
request numbers are going up so it's 40
requests 45 requests 50 requests and
we're averaging fractions of a query per
second this is easily handleable within
the single instance that we have running
so we can look at latency we can look at
errors we can look at traffic or
utilization that sort of thing okay so
not a ton of load let's go back to our
magic load generator and say hey now
we've got sort of product market fit
we've got 10,000 simultaneous users at
any given time I'm gonna click on this
button this is going to emulate lots
more users using the product thus lots
more events being written in now I
haven't had to do anything but what we
should see fairly shortly here is
additional instances getting spun up
because the queries per second goes up
so we can see it continues to go up it
hasn't spun up another instance yet so
so far so good
well let's just drop the hammer let's go
straight to a million simultaneous users
this is a lot of calls on my API clearly
more than one instance can handle now
you'll notice I've got two instances
and there we go so now you see we've got
five instances and this will keep
growing out as is required so App Engine
is using an algorithm of CPU utilization
memory utilization and requests per
second
to identify how many front-end instances
or in this case how many back-end API
service instances I need in order to
service all the incoming requests okay
so we promised you apps that scale
automatically here you go automatic app
scaling in addition to making it really
easy to scale up or down depending on
load App Engine also makes it really
easy to manage services that are in
production so let's say I want to
actually release a new version of the
front-end one of the things that I have
found is some people aren't entirely
sure what to do with this dashboard view
and I'd like to give them the
opportunity to ask questions of the
support team while they're using it so I
need to make a modification what I'm
going to do is switch to my code editor
and I'm gonna integrate a third-party
product so this is a product that
actually puts a little messenger box
onto a webpage and allows the end user
to talk to somebody within our
organization so I'm gonna copy this and
I'm going to paste it into the customer
view what we're gonna do is we're gonna
put that down here okay now this is a
new version of the application so I want
to update the versioning information I'm
going to say this is version 1-2 now
this is version 1-2 of the front end web
app service notice there's an API Events
service as well and I'm going to leave
it configured as 1-1 so because I have
my app broken into two services I can
upgrade one component without touching
the other components okay so now that
I've got that what I'm going to do is
actually deploy the service so here
is my command line and I'm going to
switch into let's see success HQ and I'm
going to deploy now this is all I have
to do to the ploy so it's one simple
command line it's taking all of my
business logic and all in my application
code and it's loading it up on top of
the App Engine infrastructure it's
automatically creating a new version of
the application
front-end keeping the old version so I
have a 1.1 version and you'll see that I
have a 1.2 version running now so what's
interesting here is I go back and I go
to versions and you'll notice that for
my API event service I only have the one
version because I haven't updated it but
if I go to default you'll notice that
there are two versions you've got the
big blue line down here and the big grey
line down here what this means is that
all of the traffic going to my
application is being served from the
initial version currently none of the
traffic is being served by the new
version so we've actually staged this
version people can only get to it if
they use a special URL which prepends
the version number this allows me to
test it in a production environment
without actually having it be live to my
end-users I can also choose to split
traffic so for instance if I click on
this and I choose migrate traffic this
will actually move all of the traffic
from the old version to the new version
or I can choose to split traffic and
this would allow me to say you know what
I want 20% of my end users to be
directed to the new version while 80%
continue to go to the old version this
would be a great way to test the
efficacy of that new widget that we put
in which I'll show you in just a sec
alright so let's try the new version I'm
going to click here it's going to open a
special URL and you'll notice I have a
new capability built in this is asking
me for a free trial because I haven't
paid for this
but you'll notice in the bottom right
hand corner now I've got this messaging
window which allows the end user
ostensibly to talk to somebody on the
back end if I click through you'll see
that this actually loads on every single
page okay I'll just miss the free trial
thing and having a little bit of
difficulty pulling up the messaging but
you can see that the widget actually
works if I go back and I try loading the
first version you'll notice that I don't
get the little plug-in so I've got two
different versions running at the same
time and right now everybody will be
directed to the default version if I
want some people to try the newly
installed feature I can send them a
special URL or again what I can do is I
can do traffic splitting I've been
showing you this running in a canned
version that I had already gotten up and
running what if I wanted to deploy this
from scratch you like Jeff okay it's
really easy once it's up and running but
maybe it was really hard to get up and
going in the first place and again not
so let's take you through the process of
deploying this from scratch so I'm going
to create a new project and we're gonna
call this success hq3
and we're going to bill it to my account
we're going to create the new project
remember a project and Google cloud
platform is a collection of applications
and resources that have a particular
billing account and a particular
security boundary so I'm going to create
a separate group of resources for this
part of the demo and then what I'm going
to do is I'm going to make a new App
Engine application so I'm opening up the
Google cloud shell which is a web UI
that has all the command line tools that
I need to manage Google cloud platform
so I'm going to create a new application
for this project and it asks me where I
want to locate the application and I'm
going to put this in the US central
region so it takes just
moment - fire up the new application but
it's an empty optical a application
there's no code there so now I need to
deploy my code so well that's going in
the background what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go into my code and I'm
gonna change this to be success hq3
and I'm going to change this to be
success hq3 and now I've got a chunk of
code I've all I've done is one short
command line in the console to create a
new application let's make sure that
that has finished running
it has okay and now what I'm going to do
is I am going to deploy my application
to my new project so this is a
first-time deployment of a brand new
application and I built this application
on my local machine I've got development
tools that Google makes available it's
super easy to do
and once it's up and running if I go
through to App Engine
I should see the default service is
there I'm still waiting for the API
events service to run okay i refresh
here
okay I can see both services are running
I can see that by default there are no
instances because nobody has tried to
access either one of the services yet
and let's try out the default service
okay so once the deployment to our new
project is done we should be able to
click on this and if all goes well we'll
see that the front-end is actually up
and running you'll notice that there's
no information for projects and renewals
and trending because this is a brand new
instance there's no data in the data
store so we would have to populate the
data but we can see that it was actually
as simple as 25 seconds of waiting with
one command line to actually deploy and
get the application up and running so
with that what we've shown is that it's
super simple to create a new project and
deploy a new application that that
application can scale servers up and
down automatically based on load that
it's really easy to upload new versions
and actually do partial releases of
those versions and you can easily
segregate your services within an
application so that you can sort of
decouple the release schedule of the API
for events and the front-end for the end
users okay is that cool hopefully you
saw something you liked let's switch
back to the presentation and talk at a
high level about the wide range of
functionality available to you in App
Engine so as you've sussed out by now
App Engine is basically a magic layer of
software that allows you to take
business logic and some application code
upload it and have it run with
little-to-no operations overhead on top
of Google's massive compute storage and
networking infrastructure you don't have
to worry about defining servers standing
them up tearing them down you'll have to
worry about replication load balancing
any of that stuff you can do all of this
in compute engine but in App Engine
and it's all sort of done for you with a
software layer that Google provides now
there are two different environments
available in App Engine what we showed
you in that demo is what's called
standard environment and what happens in
standard environment environment is you
take your code and when you deploy it
Google creates a containerized version
of your application in a quite locked
down and standardised container
environment they've got four separate
runtimes that you can use with App
Engine standard environment there's Java
Python Go and PHP so if you want to use
another language standard environment is
going to work for you don't worry
there's another environment which we'll
talk about in a second but the benefit
of having this really restricted locked
down container environment is that
Google can then apply all sorts of
automation and management magic to
reduce the operations overhead on you
when you are using standard environment
runtimes you have access to a bunch of
support services so for instance there's
a service that allows you to send and
receive emails from your application
there's a service that allows you to
resize and manipulate images there's an
API as I noted that allows you to do a
shared memcache across all of your auto
scaled server instances these are all
available to you you can do all of this
stuff without using the built-in
standard environment api's but you would
have to load client libraries and write
a little bit more code now the upside to
these very tightly constrained standard
environment runtimes is all of the
automation magic that happens the
downside is they create some constraints
which are unfamiliar to programmers
coming from other environments so for
instance you can't have background
processes you can't write to local disk
you can't install third-party runtimes
and all of your requests to your
application have to return and complete
within 60 seconds so if you're a
developer used to working in other
environments you're gonna have to learn
some new patterns to make your apps run
an app engine standard environment and
take care of sort of all of the
Meishan magic now Google understands
that for some developers this isn't a
viable solution and so they've created
something called flexible environment
and what flexible environment does is it
gives you the ability to use a wider
range of runtimes and to customize your
own runtimes
so you have to do a little bit more work
you have to actually create a docker
file that describes the configuration of
your container it does allow you to do a
variety of things you might want to do
so for instance you can support
additional languages you can support
Ruby or node or net you can install
third-party binaries you can do all the
programming stuff that you're used to
like accessing the local file system
writing to the local file system that
sort of thing you trade off though
access to some capabilities in standard
environment so for instance you have to
do a little bit more overhead defining
your docker containers configuring your
runtimes some of the api's are
unavailable if you're using non-standard
runtimes and you cannot host your
flexible environment App Engine
applications in Europe you can host it
in North America or use Pacific you can
access it from anywhere in the world but
you just can't have the app running in
the European data centers what kind of
instances does your App Engine
application have to choose from so in
standard environment your App Engine
instance classes range from the small
end of 128 megabytes and 600 megahertz
to 1 gigabyte of memory and 4.8
gigahertz in flexible environment you
can use any of the standard GCE machine
types so you have a lot of flexibility
in terms of the amount of processor and
the amount of memory in standard
environment you've got three types of
scaling you've got automatic basic and
manual so manual you would choose
exactly how many instances you want
running you would have to change the
configuration file and redeploy in order
to get more instances automatic will use
that algorithm that we talked about and
basic is sort of in-between flexible
environment also offers automat
and basic scaling but it does scaling
the same way that GCE does auto scaling
so that would be based on CPU
utilization or on like custom stack
driver metrics billing can get a little
complicated I've got a summary here I
would suggest that you actually search
on App Engine billing calculator and
they've got a fairly sophisticated
calculator where you can type in all
your parameters or run test loads and
get an idea of what the costs look like
but basic thing here is for standard
environment you get billed for instance
hours so you have no instances running
you pay no instance our fees instance
hours range from 5 cents per hour to 40
cents per hour depending on the instance
class type and then if you are using
services so for instance if you're
making calls to the data store or you're
making calls to the image API you may
pay a fee based on X number of
executions of the API Flex environment
pricing is comprised of hourly fee for
the number of CPUs you're using an
hourly fee for the amount of memory that
you're using and an hourly fee for
whatever persistent disk you have
associated with those instances and then
on top of these sort of instance charges
you pay for data store use and you pay
for network egress so any data that goes
into your App Engine application is free
any data that comes out of the GCP
region you actually have to pay for and
again that's 8 cents to 11 cents per
terabyte in North America and a little
bit more expensive say in Australia or
in China we use the Google Cloud
datastore in the demo application we use
that to store all the information about
the individual companies and the
projects and the trending information
and so forth cloud datastore is a no
sequel document database that's designed
to be very flexible so it's sort of a
schema-less
datastore and it's also high-performance
so you can scale to millions and
millions of rows and it performs quite
well
it supports atomic transaction high
availability so your data is replicated
canid across multiple physical resources
within a region and that as a result
what that means is that if a particular
device goes down or even a zone goes
down your application is still available
and your data is still there massive
scalability so as I said really fast
across many many many rows your data is
encrypted at rest and it's a fully
managed service with no play owned
downtime so you don't have to worry
about a single point of failure you
don't have to worry about it being down
Saturday mornings from 8 to 12 a.m.
Google takes care of all of that for you
and your application runs without
interruption in terms of architecting
your application App Engine provides you
a variety of features that allow you to
be more intelligent in the way that you
implement deploy and manage your
applications so we talked about services
the idea here is you can take a single
application and break it down into two
five ten or more micro services that
allows individual teams to develop each
service at a different pace and you can
roll those out with differing versions
in different times once you roll out new
versions you can roll forward you can
roll back you can split traffic between
those versions what we would do at hi-5
for instance which is a video
conferencing company that I used to work
at we would actually roll out new
features to say 10% of the user base
then to 30% of the user base and
assuming nothing caught on fire and
there weren't any screams we would roll
it out to the rest of the user base if
anything went wrong we could simply roll
it back to the previous version task
queues allow you to offload longer
running processes so we said for
instance than in standard environment
you have a 60-second time limit to
return a response to the end user what
you could do is get a request from a
user return a response immediately but
put some long-running task on a task
queue and then that can run for you know
five 10 minutes in the background
without problem there's also a new
feature that was rolled out is just in
February of 2017 called cloud endpoint
frameworks
this is a mechanism by which you can
expose api's using Google's open API
cloud proxy and this provides better
security better scalability standardized
interface and automatically generated
JavaScript clients that you can include
in your applications to make use of your
API s so given all those capabilities
whether it's standard environment
flexible environment whether you're
using a back-end datastore of cloud
datastore or you're using say bigquery
question do you want to ask yourself is
what can you do with Google App Engine
you may have heard of a company called
snap previously known as snapchat what
they were able to do with App Engine is
grow within a few years from 0 to 700
million plus photos and videos shared
every day with a very small development
team and an even smaller operations team
they were able to focus exclusively on
business logic and application
functionality and the scale just
happened in the backend you may have
seen that they've made a forward
commitment to spend 2 billion dollars on
Google cloud platform services over the
next five years so obviously it's a long
term bet for them your application
probably isn't going to be this big but
one can hope so let's say you leave the
session today and as you're working with
App Engine you have questions or you
need a little bit of guidance on how to
do specific things where do you look so
you start with search Google preferably
and you can search for GAE short for
Google App Engine and your topic of
interest so for instance here we've got
J versions and the first link is a link
to App Engine standard environment and
then you've got the ability to do
deploying versions and so forth
there's also App Engine and your topic
of interest sometimes GAE isn't sort of
specific enough and putting App Engine
will work better the documentation is a
little bit different than what you have
seen with other Google cloud platform
products so you still at one point end
up with this nice table of contents
which got quick star
our how-to guides api references
concepts tutorials and so forth but
there's a level of organization above
this and it would actually be helpful if
I just show this to you so if we look at
Google App Engine I always start with
search I'm going to go to App Engine
platform so this is sort of the overview
page if I click on View App Engine Docs
what you'll notice is it doesn't take me
to the table of contents instead it
takes me to a table of contents that
asks me what language I'm using and
they've actually got versions of the
documentation for all of the popular
languages so I use Python primarily so
if we look at Python then you have the
next level which is choose your
preferred environment do you want
flexible environment or standard
environment when you click here this
will then take you to the familiar table
of contents section but they have a
different one of these pages in
different subordinate sections for each
combination of language and environment
so keep that in mind as you're looking
around now as you're considering App
Engine for your environment a few things
to consider one follow a process figure
out what it is you need to know in order
to make a decision and what success is
sort of what threshold you need to cross
in order to determine that App Engine is
in fact the solution for you think about
how you're going to test are you going
to lift an existing application and put
it in App Engine the answer to that is
often no certainly not for standard
environment because there are a lot of
structural changes that you might need
to make you could lift an application
from a containerized environment perhaps
and put it on flexible environment but
figure out what you're going to do
probably something like a Minimum Viable
Product or a prototype of something new
that you're wanting to build figure out
who's on the team you're going to need
somebody to design the test product
you're going to need software engineers
you need somebody to product or project
manage
the entire evaluation process and then
decision makers to whom you report the
results and they help make the decision
no you need to be comfortable or you
need to get designers or developers that
are comfortable in order to make this
evaluation worthwhile if you're gonna
get developers who are very entrenched
in another development methodology and
they're not particularly keen to learn
how to work with app engines specific
constraints then it's probably not the
right person to have involved in your
evaluation or that's not the right use
case to attempt to move to App Engine
what you want is somebody who's willing
to pick up the specific rules and
patterns for designing and developing
for App Engine in order to get all the
benefits out in the operations side
again follow a timeline so typically you
can make an application that proves out
how well App Engine will work for you
within a month it's more complicated
it'll take longer if you have more
people it'll take less time and you want
to break it down into three phases
there's a phase where you define your
criteria and you recruit your team and
you agreeing on your high level tests
there's a section of time where you do
some research you do some point testing
you make sure you actually understand
how App Engine works and how you're
gonna build your thing you build it and
then ultimately you perform your tests
and you're testing probably for
performance you're testing for
functionality and developer productivity
you're testing for pricing and then you
collect all of those results you analyze
them and you make a decision and
hopefully this gives you a sense of all
the things you can do with App Engine
and how you can try App Engine out for
your use cases to make a good decision
and that's it for this session thanks so
much for joining us I hope you learn
something and that you found interesting
and useful we'll be sending you a
follow-up email that has a link to a
code lab so you can get some guided
experience with App Engine yourself we'd
love to get your feedback so feel free
to provide that feedback on the screen
and stay tuned for our next session
you